>> CHRIS: We are StudyBlue, Inc. We're based
in Madison, Wisconsin, and we're an academic
network for both college and high school students.
We provide study tools for students to organize
their academic life by organizing their college
material and high school material online such
as notes and flash cards collaborating with
others and sharing that material as well as
using some of our unique tools to help them
study more efficiently.
>> What tools did you use?
>> CHRIS: We have used extensively the Google
Web Toolkit. We've been using that since we
started and since it started several years
ago.
>> And as a developer can you give us a worth
story and lessons learned?
>> CHRIS: Sure. Ernie [PH] are going to touch
on some development issues. It's been a unique
battle of integrating programming and design
together with GWT.
>> ERNIE [PH]: Yeah. We've been at some challenges
in that. Chris is doing most of the development
and I'm doing most of front end and some of
those challenges just involve--while he's
working in GWT and I'm working on some of
the text that are on the CSS and how we're
working with hosted mode but we're excited
to see at the conference here today that GWT
is kind of implementing some new things of
hosted mode to really help us out there and
allow us to work more efficiently and allow
me to kind of proof and browse some of the
new things they're doing, I’m pretty exciting.
>> CHRIS: Yeah. We were originally sitting
right next to each other and to share computer
screens, but it's moving to that kind of thing
that we can interact into much more efficient
ways with the use in some of the new features.
>> So, speaking of new features what are the
top three features?
>> CHRIS: Well, some of the features we're
looking at that we're excited about certainly
out of process hosted mode, the ability to
debug and test using any browser anywhere.
Some other features that you were excited
about?
>> SEAN: Well, one thing we really love in
studying Google is that GD [PH], the incorporate
inauguration of GD [PH] with hosted mode,
you know, it will make it easier for us to
restart the server code without even, you
know, have into like shutdown and redeploy
the code.
>> CHRIS: Yeah. And out of process hosted
mode will allow debug everything in the browsers
that we're most comfortable with, you know,
including Firefox, and certainly the new event
handling structure or something we're pretty
excited about being able to fire an event
from anywhere and handle that event and only
add events to widgets that are necessary.
So, we're excited about that.
>> You're upgrading from 1.5 to 1.6. Can you
tell us a little bit about that?
>> CHRIS: It's actually a funniest story.
We did that on the way to the conference,
Sean was in-charge there.
>> SEAN: Yeah. So, pretty much all I did is
I go into the apps tone using my iPhone, downloaded
the SSH client and was able to connect to
our server upgrades the GWT library and we
deploy it and it was ready in less than two
minutes and we were on the plane waiting to
take off.
>> So, you've mentioned you have about things
you like to see at Google products. Can you
tell us different things about that?
>> CHRIS: Yeah. Some improvements, you know,
search engine optimization is certainly a
big one, Ernie [PH] could talk to that a little
while.
>> ERNIE [PH]: Yeah. It's a big one for us
for trying to open up more of our content
to be more indexed, more publicly accessible
but [INDISTINCT] a lot of content. Yeah, we
definitely [INDISTINCT] in the search engine
optimization. We need to get off our content
index and it's definitely one of the challenges
that they acknowledged with the software right
now, but we're encourage to hear what they're
talking about at the conference here, and
how they tackling in the near future. So that
will be indexed and we'll get off our content
out there.
>> CHRIS: And, you know, C [PH] as our entire
application is belt with GWT, we really don’t
have any HTML pages. It's all in one page,
all JavaScript, you know, tons of thousands
aligns at the JavaScript and having AdSense
or the search engine bots being able to crawl
and integrate our webapp with those existing
Google services is something we definitely
looking forward to, so.
>> Okay. We want to thank you for joining
us today. We hope you have a great Google
I/O.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks. We appreciate it.